Kerry Lake was confronted by Piers
Morgan in the interview I've been
waiting for for a long time you know I
I'm not a particularly big fan of Piers
Morgan and in fact his producers have
been extraordinarily unprofessional in
their dealings with me and and just
their lack of organization and
discussions we've had about me appearing
with them but this is just fantastic I I
hold no grudge and I I blame him not at
all for that he does a fantastic job
here in confronting failed Arizona
Republican gubernatorial candidate Kerry
Lake and he straight up says her there's
no evidence that you really won she
insists I won
she insists there were irregularities my
opponent cheated we've got lawsuits all
this different stuff take a look at this
and look at how flustered she gets
really nicely done by Pierce all right
there's been no independent
corroboration that there was anything
fraudulent about this election in fact
it's pretty clear that you lost to Katie
Hobbs your your rival 50.3 to 49.6 and
as with Donald Trump and I said to
where's the hard evidence he went down
all sorts of rabbit holes but he
couldn't produce there's a ton of peers
Pierce there's there's there's a
mountain of Hard Evidence and when we
presented it in our trial the other side
didn't even dispute the evidence now
that's such a lie it it's it's so
deceptive when she says that the other
side didn't dispute the evidence she
says they didn't need to because the
so-called evidence was nothing it was so
faulty and bogus that a judge said I
don't even have anything here to
potentially move forward on remember
that they made 10 complaints lengths to
a court
eight of the ten complaints they simply
had no grounds for whatsoever the other
two complaints the judge heard and said
okay what do you have and the judge said
there's nothing here it's like if I go
into court and I say bananas are
actually electric vehicles and the judge
says that's nonsense we can't move
forward with that and then I go the
other side never disputed it I said that
bananas are elected they never well no
it's the judge said it's so absurd we're
not even moving forward and Carrie likes
well but they didn't dispute it she is
such a liarsity
yes well we can't continue to run
elections this way and we know that we
won and we're going to continue to fight
this in a court of law and it's really
rich that you're sitting across the pond
acting like you know what you can't
possibly know whether I won peers if
you're in London happened on Election
Day I did not see your smiling face we
had lots of international media here
covering elections it would have made no
difference her opponent got more votes
today in Arizona yours is one face I
didn't see and nor did I see it you
could have had my spotting face
arizonans
I would have loved to have seen you we
had more media covering our election
than I've ever seen cover any any story
here wow and despite the record media
coverage they still got away with
cheating that's stunning Carrie Zona and
as I said I covered Arizona for nearly
30 years so it's okay that you are not
comfortable with me fighting this
election and fighting for election
Integrity
I don't I don't mind your fighting
spirit I don't mind it in Donald Trump
I've known him a long time well I have
every right to fight this election
absolutely no one's arguing it isn't her
right it's just baseless and she's
grifting
but it does come on point and you're
doing this
it does come a point when for the future
of democracy you and Donald Trump have
to accept at some point you lost an
election otherwise the entire system
collapses if your simple response to
losing is always we didn't lose we won
then democracy diets
Pierce I grew up in a family of nine I'm
the youngest my father oh well that
changes everything then there was a
history and government teacher and a
football coach and he taught us that if
we lose and we lose fair and square we
we congratulate the winner we walk away
and that's exactly what I would do if
that was a fair and square election but
I'm fighting for the people of Arizona I
go I mean guys our dad coached football
obviously she wouldn't lie over this
country I've been probably to Six States
since the election in Arizona I can't
walk 10 feet without an arizonan saying
I voted for you everybody I know voted
for you our ballot was rejected on
Election Day please keep fighting for us
I'm fighting for the people of Arizona
every 10 feet people are saying it was
stolen that's stunning stuff huh and I I
don't mean any offense to you but I
frankly don't give a damn what you think
about it I'm fighting people in Arizona
I totally am no offense taken whatsoever
let me excuse this Pierce let me ask let
me ask you a question do you think it's
right that you show up on Election Day
that's the big day on Election Day and
60 percent of the voting locations in
the primarily Republican locations have
ballots that are printed out wrong
machines
albeit from mine is that okay all I know
from my lofty uh place here in London
and I admit I wasn't in Arizona it's too
far to know what happened guys London's
very there's water in between that is
all the official fact-checking entities
that have looked into all the claims do
not conclude everything
come on
Pierce Pierce did you just fall off the
turnip truck we know about the fact
Checkers and we've seen them this has
all been guys despite record media
coverage of the race the media didn't
notice the cheating by Katie Hobbs
because the media is complicit and the
fact Checkers didn't notice the cheating
by Haiti Katie Hobbs because the fact
Checkers are just left-wing loons and
the courts didn't recognize Carrie
Lake's evidence because the judges are
left-wing loons even though many of them
are Republicans revealed half of them
are leftists working for face there it
is let's be real okay
at what point would you accept that
you've lost never
well we're do you think that we have a
right to move this through the court
system he already said it's not a
question of whether you have a right
Carrie I think we do I know that we do
we have the rights
anyway you see the the direction this is
going she sort of has to do this because
at a certain point if she just goes hey
you know what
I was wrong I just lost
she can never run again and she's
thinking about running for Senate and
she wants to have a political career so
really really nice job there by Piers
Morgan Carey lake is a liar and a
grifter and I know she doesn't really
think she won she knows she lost but she
has to do this
plastic it's everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year here's something super
simple you can do to reduce plastic and
help the planet a little bit our sponsor
hold on bags is the company making
plastic free trash bags and zip seal
kitchen bags they're just as strong and
high quality as the plastic bags you're
used to hold on bags are 100 percent
plant-based and home compostable meaning
they break down in just weeks not
decades their zip seal kitchen bags come
in sandwich or gallon size to fit all of
your needs whether it's carrots or
crayons at home I put all of my food
waste in a hold on trash bag throw it in
the compost pile and when I throw a hold
on trash bag in my dumpster I love
knowing it's not filling our landfills
and oceans with plastic single use
Plastics harm the planet at every Stage
production disposal decomposition join
the growing movement away from
single-use plastic these products are
really great it's so easy to make the
switch go to hold on bags.com
Pacman and you'll get 20 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below